it's punching it's kicking armored
combat is sort of like MMA but with
weapons to me this is the ultimate
combat sport
my name is Andres Inoue I'm the
co-founder of the armored combat league
I'm the captain of the national sword
fighting team the USA Knights our form
of armored combat started a little over
four years ago it came to our ears that
there were some people over in Europe
that we're doing this and we had to
build the United States team and trying
to be competitive with the world most of
the arms and armor that we use comes
from the late 14th an early 15th century
Western Europe now there's some other
armors but the best bang for the buck
it is usually late 14th century or early
15th century armor it's kind of
counterintuitive but if you're wearing
decent armor and you get hit with a
sword half the time you don't even know
you've been hit if you played football
you'd done a rougher thing
it's a brawl I mean there's no doubt
about it you're going out there and
you're brawling just like in rugby or a
football you've got to have a plan when
you go out there the flankers end up
with three people on them and you end up
with two now melees are a lot more
intense those rules are you fight until
submission or until you put somebody
down to the ground there's no typical
person for armoured combat you've got
people from all walks of life whether
it's some sort of martial arts or
football or rugby there's some history
buffs - and they'll fight and fight and
fight and they'll give everything to the
point of exhaustion that's what makes a
winner it's all here these guys will go
hard at each other they're gonna be
swinging as hard as they can they're
trying to knock you down they're trying
to get you to submit and then they're
gonna help you up they're gonna patch on
the back and there you go have a steak
and a beer with you
you